>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Al Weisner: [Background
noise] I think you're very,
very lucky today, to
have Shannon here.
She's written over 20 books, many
of them New York Times best-sellers.
She's written about 3 or
4 books on, for adults.
You might ask her about, her small
plastic pig pet when she comes
up here for questions and answers,
and her family that
lives in Salt Lake.
So Shannon, thank you
for being here.
>> Shannon Hale: Thank you so much.
Hi everybody.
I'm Tweeting this so
I need pictures.
Everybody wave, yay.
Oh, on this side wave, yay.
Oh what a great, this
is an awesome festival.
I was up in the, author
pavilion which is
like a perk of being an author.
Because you get to go
into the secret room.
And there's like Kareem
Abdul,-Jabbar and Ken Burns
and [inaudible] and I'm like yeah,
no big deal, These are my peers.
We totally hung out, a few tables
away from each other but still,
the same room, oh, I went, too fast.
Oh you see cute picture?
Who is that?
Oh my God, you're like so
adorable, look at that little face.
My mom told me that was making
up stories before I could talk.
She said I'd sit in my
highchair, for hours on end going.
[baby talk]
Your first question is why were you
in your highchair for hours, right?
I was a third child.
But I kept telling
stories, and as I got older,
before I could write stories,
down I would draw pictures.
Did you know that pictures is
just another form of storytelling?
So before I could write, this is
in kindergarten, I told a story
about a witch with
long green fingernails.
And she ate children.
But look at her smile.
She's fulfilled in her work
and you have to respect that.
As I got older, I found other ways
to tell stories, I
loved doing theater.
I would do little plays with
my brothers and sisters,
and act out stories with my friends.
And then when I got into
fourth grade, there we are,
any children of the 80s in here?
Feathered, feathered bangs.
I had a teacher who started us
writing poems and short stories.
And I suddenly realized,
that you could do that.
That all those books in the library,
had, someone had written those.
And I think I'd thought that,
that all writers were dead
or like long extinct like dinosaurs.
I didn't know, until I started
writing, that maybe they were alive.
When I was little we
didn't get to meet writers,
we didn't have access to writers.
So that was a huge revelation
for me and I decided right then,
I wanted to be a writer
when I grew up.
And it took a lot longer
than I thought.
I was 10 years old when I
decided I wanted to be a writer.
Any guesses how many more years
after that I got my
first book published?
What do you think?
3? Someone said.
It was 19 years, and
that's not unusual
but it felt like forever for me.
But in that time I
read thousands of books
which is the most important part
of becoming a writer is reading
and knowing what's out there.
And absorbing how stories work.
And I'd taken many writing classes.
I decided that you needed
to do something 100 times
before you can do it well.
So I wrote 100 stories, I threw
them away, and then I thought,
I'm finally ready to
be a real writer.
By the time I was in graduate school
I felt like I'd written some stuff
that was finally worth publishing.
I started sending my book and
some short stories out to see
if anyone wanted to publish them.
Which means, put them into book
form and have them in libraries,
and bookstores where
people can get them.
I waited to hear back, I got
the first response in the mail.
I opened up the letter, and
what do you think it said?
No? It said no?
All right, but I wasn't
going to quit right?
So I sent it out again, I
waited to hear back again,
I got a second response, I open it
up, what did it you say this time?
No? You, there are so
many people who are
like we know how the world works.
There's like a 5 year-old
like, it says no, come on.
Again, and again, and
again, I got no, no, no.
Can I have a helper?
Would you help me?
No? Right here, who
wants to help me?
You want to help me?
Come here.
She's like I'm not, she's smart,
she's like I'm not committing
to anything without a full
explanation beforehand.
Here, come up on stage.
I laminated into a role, some
of the rejection letters I got,
before I ever got an acceptance.
Stay back there, okay sweetheart?
Oh, you're adorable.
Okay now grab that end,
it's kind of slippery.
Keep pulling it out and then
when you get to the end,
hold it real tight and
we'll hold it up for them.
Wow, you are doing a great
job, it's actually really hard
to do this slippery thing.
So day after day, week
after week, year after year,
rejection after rejection,
after rejection,
telling me I was not good enough.
It's kind of like getting letters,
every week from New York saying,
dear Shannon, you stink,
love the editors.
And the next one's
like dear Shannon,
you still stink, love the editors.
Dear Shannon, you stink so bad
we can smell you all the way
from New York City,
love the editors.
And there was just no guarantee it
was ever going to stop, you got it?
Okay, hold it tight, I'm
just going to pull it
out so that everybody can see.
There we go.
Thank you, sweetheart,
you did such a great job,
you can go back down now.
But let me just give you
a little thank you, mask.
You can give her a little
hand, isn't she wonderful?
Fearless. Eventually it
did stop, the hard thing
with rejection is you don't
know that it's going to stop.
And it takes a lot
of faith and maybe,
a lot of tears and a lot of pain.
And I didn't give up and
sometimes I don't why I didn't.
When everybody's telling
you you're not good enough,
it's, I wanted to give up.
But I couldn't bear the thought,
of someday looking back
and thinking what if.
It's a horrible feeling.
So I did keep going and
eventually, somebody said yes.
The first thing I ever got
published was called The Goose Girl,
everybody, oh, thank you.
Well, that's it I'm
out thanks folks.
The Goose Girl was
rejected by everybody.
And eventually a small publisher,
published it as the second book
they'd ever published in the U.S.
And it went on to, be voted by
teens across the U.S. as one
of their top 10 favorite books
and recently was voted as one
of their top 100 best books
of all time for teens.
So all those people who said it
wasn't good enough, were they right?
Yes, they were.
Because although of course they were
wrong to say I wasn't good enough
for anybody, it wasn't
right for them.
And that's what rejection
has taught me.
Is it's not that you're
worthless, when you're rejected,
it's just, it's this is not right.
This person, this circumstance,
this time, this is not right.
It's not that you're not right,
this circumstance is not right.
And we keep going and
eventually, we find a home.
I published a few more books,
Princess Academy, thanks
folks, I'm out.
I need to leave when
there's applause,
you got to end on a high note.
There's some new covers for that but
anyway, Ever After High is a series
that I did that was a lot of fun.
In our family, we love super heroes,
and I've told a lot
of super hero stories.
This is my husband's son, Batman
and Robin, that's to scale.
Here's my daughter, Wonder Woman.
One thing having kids showed me is
that a kid is not just
one thing, right?
You're complicated.
You've got a lot of sides to
you, you could be Wonder Woman,
you can be a princess, you can be
a fairy, you can be Spider Girl.
You can be a pirate,
you can be a tiger,
you can be a warrior,
all wrapped into one.
And my husband and I wanted to
write a story that expressed that.
That someone can be more
than just one thing.
And we came up with the
Princess in Black, so, yay.
So Princess in Black, so she's
Princess Magnolia by day,
and the Princess in Black
whenever monsters invade.
This came about, one day my
daughter, who was 4 at the time,
was wearing this butterfly
skirt, and she was pointing
to different colors on it.
And she said, pink is a girl
color, and purple's a girl color,
and yellow's a girl
color, but not black.
And I was like, what?
Girls can wear black, why do
colors have genders anyway?
It doesn't make any sense.
Like, did you know 100 years ago
boys wore pink and girls wore blue?
It just doesn't make any
sense, how this happened.
But I was like girls can
wear black, I wear black.
And she's like, yeah, because you're
not really a girl, you're a mama.
I was like all right.
But Bat Girl wears black, ah huh.
I thought I had her.
But she said mama,
princesses don't wear black.
It's like woah, it was
one of those moments,
I couldn't stop thinking
about it all day.
When my husband came home from
work, I was like the Princess
in Black and he's like yes.
And so we started writing it.
And I am going to, we've
done 3 books so far,
we've got the fourth
coming out in November.
The Princess in Black,
the Princess in Black,
in the second one has a birthday
party and these are her, friends,
12 princesses come to her party.
They're all named after
flowers like Princess Bluebell
and Princess Apple Blossom.
The one on the top left,
is Princess Sneezewort,
and the illustrator Lay-Win Fam
based her on her own young self,
with awkward self-cut
bangs and huge glasses.
She's my favorite.
The newest one is called
the Princess in Black,
and the Hungry Bunny Hoard.
And I'm going to read you
an abbreviated version
of the first few chapters.
Princess Magnolia and her
unicorn Frimplepants rode toward
the village.
Princess Sneezewort had
invited them to brunch.
In anticipation, Frimplepants
had skipped breakfast.
The café was so close, the smell
of hot bread rode the breeze,
Frimplepants began to prance.
And then Princess Magnolia's glitter
stone ring rang, the monster alarm.
No time to go back to
the castle Frimplepants,
Princess Magnolia whispered.
To the secret cave.
His tummy grumbled, Frimplepants
hoped it would be a quick battle.
Princess Magnolia and Frimplepants
rode into the secret cave
when they came out the other
side, they had become the Princess
in Black and her pony,
does anybody know?
What's his name?
Blackie, yay.
Blackie reared on his hind
legs, look out monsters,
never get between a hungry pony
and an especially good brunch.
Duff the goat boy was running
toward them, help, he yelled,
there are hundreds of them, it's
the worst monster invasion ever.
Fly Blackie, fly, said
the Princess in Black.
Blackie did not fly, but
he did run very fast.
They galloped into the goat pasture,
the Princess in Black back
flipped off the saddle,
the Princess in Black raised
her fists in battle pose.
And then, the Princess in Black
grinned, bunnies, she said.
When Duff the goat boy caught up,
the Princess in Black
was not battling beasts.
The Princess in Black was making
kissy faces, that was not right.
The Princess in Black
always fought the monsters
that threatened his goats.
Never had she pet the monsters,
never had she made
kissy faces at them.
Where are the monsters?
Asked the Princess in Black.
Duff was out of breath from running.
He pointed at the ground, where?
Asked the Princess in Black.
Duff pointed some more, there
were a lot of bunnies to point at.
But I don't see anything
besides these bunnies, she said.
The bunnies, are the
monsters, said Duff.
The Princess in Black laughed,
bunnies aren't monsters.
But they came from
Monster Land, said Duff,
they hopped out of the hole and
they're eating my goat's grass.
Oh Duff, said the Princess in Black,
they're cute little bunnies,
what harm could they do?
Down in Monster Land, the bunnies
had been bored, bored and hungry.
They had enjoyed monster fur,
they had snacked on rock chips,
they had dined on toenail
clippings and lizard scales,
and still, they were hungry.
There was a hole in the
ceiling of Monster Land,
an interesting smell trickled down,
one brave bunny had poked
its head through the hole.
Grass, an ocean of green grass.
I must taste it, said the bunny.
The bunny munched some
grass, this is yum, it said.
I should tell the others.
It told the others and
soon, hundreds of bunnies
that hopped up to the goat pasture.
Blackie's stomach squeaked
with a hunger,
those bunnies sure seem
to relish the grass.
And Blackie wondered if it
were especially delicious.
Blackie closed his eyes, he
imagined the grass would be
as delicious as brunch.
He opened his mouth wide and
bit, he sputtered and coughed,
it hadn't tasted like doughnuts.
It hadn't even tasted like grass,
Blackie had a mouthful of dirt.
The bunnies had devoured
the entire patch of grass.
And it looked like one was
nibbling on the end of his tail.
Blackie switched his tail,
the bunny did not let go.
Blackie pranced about,
Blackie sat down, on his
tail, the bunny let go.
The bunny crawled away.
Just then a clawed paw
reached out of the hole,
the first paw was followed
by 8 more.
A massive drooling 9
armed monster emerged,
it stood on its many hind legs.
It opened its jaws, it said, roar.
The bunnies stopped eating,
they looked at the monster.
Ro, the monster started,
but it had seen the bunnies.
Its eyes widened, the
bunnies noses wiggled.
The 9 armed monster
dived back into the hole,
the bunnies resumed eating.
Did you see, said Duff.
That massive drooling 9 armed
monster was scared of the bunnies.
That's impossible, said the Princess
in Black, bunnies aren't scary.
She pet the bunny on her lap,
but instead of one
bunny, now there were 3.
Bom, bom bom.
I'm going to stop there.
What is going to happen next?
Oh my goodness.
What's going to happen
with the bunnies?
Now some of you might be
interested in writing,
stories about super heroes.
Can I have 3 volunteers come up?
Would you like to come up?
Yeah, come on up.
Oh, both of you can come.
How about right over
there in the, red shirt?
Yeah? Come on up.
>> Me?
>> Yeah, come on up sir.
Here we go.
You know what I have one more,
so why don't you come too, okay?
All right, here we go.
I'm going to put on my
special Princess in Black mask.
It's still me, it's still Shannon.
I know for a second you were
like wait a minute
who's the masked person?
It was me, don't get confused.
All right, now when
I write a super hero,
one thing I like to start with,
with the Princess in Black,
we chose somebody that no one
would ever suspect was secretly a
super hero.
So I want you all, you all can do
this in your heads, but up here too,
you're going to tell us, your ideas.
And, if you can't think of
one right away I can help you.
But, because we got to be fast.
So first of all, I want you to think
of someone no one would suspect
of secretly being a super hero, like
a princess in a fluffy pink dress.
Or, the lunch lady, or your mom,
or your pet, or someone real
or someone made up,
it could be anything.
All right, who are
you going to choose?
>> My fishy.
>> Your fishy, what's
your fish's name?
>> Fishy.
>> Fishy, all right.
And who are you going to?
>> Lunch lady.
>> Lunch lady, awesome, and
who are you going to choose?
>> The, Cinderella's step-mom.
>> Cinderella's step-mom.
Who are you going to choose?
>> Raven Queen.
>> Raven Queen, okay.
These are people no one suspects
as secretly a super hero.
Now like the Princess in Black,
she's got a super hero name, right?
Her secret identity
is Princess Magnolia.
But then when she,
when there's trouble,
she puts on her super hero
outfit and has a new name.
What is Fishy's super hero name?
>> Ultimate fishy.
>> Ultimate Fishy.
Oh my gosh, are you dying?
So, the lunch lady right?
What's the lunch lady's
super hero name?
>> Super Lunch Lady.
Now Cinderella's step-mom,
what's her super hero name?
>> Blackie.
And Raven Queen, what's
her super hero name?
>> Midnight.
>> Midnight, great.
Now think about what your super
hero's special skills are.
Princess' Black is kind of like
a Batman or Zorro, she's got,
kind of like ninja fighting skills.
What is the Flash's super power?
Really fast, right?
What is Superman's super power?
>> Laser eyes.
>> He's go laser eyes and
he's strong and he flies, oh,
he's so full of himself, really.
Enough already with
the powers, okay.
So you guys think, what are,
what's your super hero's powers,
what is Ultimate Fishy's powers?
>> Ultimate camouflage
and laser eyes.
Obviously, okay Super Lunch Lady,
what's Super Lunch
Lady's super powers?
>> She has lunch related
like weapons.
>> Lunch related weapons.
Absolutely, that is fantastic, yes.
And, how about, what was it?
Blackie, Blackie's super powers?
>> A lot of knives and
really sharp things.
>> A lot of knives and sharp things.
Ninja with lots of sharp things.
You would stay away
from Cinderella's step-mother,
with lots of knives.
All right, and Midnight, what
is Midnight's super powers?
>> She'd be able to do
gymnastics, but like a ninja,
and she'd use the powers
that she has.
>> Yes, so she's got magic powers
and she can also fight like a ninja
and do gymnastics, awesome.
So one more thing that you need.
Do you know the word nemesis?
Nemesis is like somebody's
number one enemy.
When you think of Batman,
who's his nemesis?
What do you think?
>> Joker.
>> Joker, great.
So think of your character's
number one enemy,
who is Ultimate Fishy's nemesis?
>> Batman.
>> Batman?
Batman. In this world
Batman is a villain,
is always trying to
stop Ultimate Fishy.
All right how about Lunch Lady's,
Super Lunch Lady's ultimate nemesis?
>> A gigantic robot school bus.
All right, and let's see it
was the, Cinderella's step-mom
when she's super hero,
what's her nemesis?
>> Her real daughter.
>> Her real daughters,
she's always battling.
And then, Midnight, what
is, who's her nemesis?
>> Her mom.
>> Her mom, oh, awesome.
Let me give you guys special
super hero masks, no one will know
who you are, and you
can save the day.
>> Can we keep it?
>> You can keep it, yeah.
Thank you, give them a
hand, you're awesome.
You guys can go back
down now, good job.
You can go back down the
stairs, good job, thank you.
All right we've got
a few more minutes,
did anybody have any
questions for me?
Is there a special microphone or
something that travels around?
Oh right here on both
sides are microphones,
if you want to ask me a question.
Do you want to go over
to the microphone
so everybody can hear
you, Yeah, right there.
>> Hi, I know that you
write a lot of series,
like the Princess Academy, and the
new ones, how do you make the books,
keep, like your readers
will keep reading them,
like plot form [inaudible].
Like every other series
that have been written?
>> You're so sweet.
So, what I personally do, is I think
of every book as standing
on its own.
I actually don't plot out whole
series, I have vague ideas,
but I want any book and any series,
that if that's the only book you
read, it would still be a good read
and have a beginning
and middle and an end.
So I think about books
as one at a time.
I don't know if that's
what it is or not but.
Oh, I almost tripped on
something, yes right here.
>> Why did you name
Mary after a flower?
>> Yes, so In Princess Academy
the main character's name is Mary,
and I said it was named
after a mountain flower.
And I totally made that up.
There's no Mary flower.
Though maybe if there's
anybody in botanist in her,
and you discover a flower
someday you could name it Mary
and that it would be for real.
I just like the word, yeah.
>> Hi, as someone who plans
to study creative writing
and foreign languages in college,
I was wondering what inspired you
to base the magic system in
The Goose Girl on languages?
>> Oh, thank you.
So The Goose Girl, my first novel,
was based on a Grimm's
Brother Fairy tale.
And it was my favorite
fairy tale growing up.
But partly because it left
me asking a lot of questions.
In the fairy tale, there's stuff
that's just never explained.
Fairy tales are so
brief and fragmented.
And, so, she had this power over
wind and she had a talking horse.
And how these things
worked never was explained.
So in exploring, when
I'm writing a novel,
you want the magic
system to make sense.
I want it to feel plausible
and real.
So I explored the idea of, language
since the horse could speak.
What if everything has a language?
What if wind had a language?
And if you learned the language
of the wind, you would control it,
fire and water, and trees and
everything else came out of that.
So that was the kernel, thank you.
Right here.
>> What would your secret power be?
>> What would my secret power be?
Well, it wouldn't be so
secret if I told you.
I have 4 kids, so I
personally would like, like,
like Elastigirl, you know.
Where you can just like, reach
and like grab and stop a child
from falling off a banister and make
dinner at the same time, you know.
That's what I would
do, is that boring?
No, come on, I would fly, right?
Who wouldn't fly?
Yeah.
>> Are you planning
any young adult books?
>> I am. I write for every
age group from The Princess
in Black up through adult.
And in February, the
next book I have coming
out is called Squirrel Girl.
It's based on the Marvel
super hero Squirrel Girl.
Yes, got some [inaudible].
She's fabulous, she has
the proportional strength
and agility of a squirrel.
She speaks squirrel language,
and she's unbeatable.
She has beat every, [inaudible]
a Marvel villain including,
Galactus and Thanos and Dr. Doom.
And she's hysterical,
she's so funny.
I can't wait for it.
Since we have a sign language
interpreter, I too want to add
that one of the main
characters in the story is deaf.
And we have a really, a wonderful
beta reader for Squirrel Girl
who is deaf, developed a Squirrel
Girl name sign name for us.
Can I teach it to you?
So I'll teach it to everybody.
Take your non-dominant hand,
and make the S with it.
Take your dominant hand, so if
you're right handed for example,
and make the G. And then coming
off the S, you do the swoop
of a squirrel tail with the
G, and that's Squirrel Girl.
Isn't that awesome?
I love that.
All right, right over here.
>> When is the new Princess
in Black book coming out?
>> Thank you.
It is coming out in,
November, number 4,
Princess in Black takes a vacation.
And I bet you can guess that
the vacation doesn't go quite
as planned.
Yes?
>> How did you think of the
characters in your books?
>> Just in all of them or do
you have a specific book you're
thinking about?
>> More like Ever After High.
>> Okay. So Ever After
High, actually was unusual
because Mattel had
created this line of toys.
And they were going to
make shows and they came
to me before it was released,
it was so secret I had to sign
on disclosure agreements.
We had to use code
names, it was crazy,
they flew me out to Mattel
headquarters in California,
it was this big building
with no windows.
We went down like secret passageways
that had all of these like,
codes to get in [inaudible].
And when I saw the dolls
they were underneath a shroud
and I could only like
peek under them.
It was like, I felt like a spy.
Anyway, so they actually created
those characters and then, I came in
and wrote the first book,
and we had such a great time.
I ended up writing 4 books for that,
but, in that case I didn't actually,
I helped, I helped flush out
the characters, probably,
but they had the initial
names and ideas.
Right over here.
>> How many super heroes
have you made?
have I made?
I personally consider
every book I've written
as being a super hero story.
That's kind of my secret.
They all feel like
super heroes to me.
But I would, I guess, the Princess
in Black, the Squirrel Girl,
I'm going to write a
Captain Marvel novel,
those would be my true super heroes.
I wrote a young and old
book called Dangerous
which was my super hero
science fiction novel.
So, I don't know, a few dozen.
I'm really good at math.
Yes, right here.
>> Why'd you name all of the
princesses after flowers?
>> Oh, so Princess Magnolia,
is named after a flower
because she's named after my
daughter whose name is Magnolia.
And then when we had 12 more
princesses we thought it would be
fun to continue that theme.
And I just love flower names.
Yes?
>> What is Princess Academy about?
>> Princess Academy is about a
village, at the top of a mountain,
and the way they make a living is
they query stone, they cut blocks
of stone out of the mountain.
They're very poor.
And one day a messenger
from the king comes up
and says their village has
been chosen as the place
where the next princess
will come from.
And all of the girls, had
never been to school before,
and they're all sent to a school,
called the Princess Academy
to learn what they need to
know in case they are chosen.
And they are reluctant about this,
they don't trust the low-landers,
they don't really believe one of
them has to become a princess.
But in the process of learning stuff
at the school, it changes
their life.
Yes, right here.
>> How did it make you feel
when you wrote the book?
>> When I wrote a book?
>> Yeah, when you wrote
Princess in Black.
>> When I wrote Princess in Black.
It made me feel like this.
Yes, I love it.
The one reason why I keep writing,
even though it's really hard,
for me and I make a lot of mistakes,
is there's no feeling in the world
like finishing a draft or
finishing the whole book
and feeling great about it.
It's the best feeling.
Yes.
>> Hi, what is some advice you
have for young writers or writers
that want to continue
writing in the future?
>> Thank you.
My advice would be, read everything.
For people, for everybody, I
would say read what you love,
for writers, I say read everything.
You need to know, not just the
kind of books that you write
but everything that's out there.
Write for fun, just write for fun,
don't worry about publishing
right now,
don't worry about all
that side of it.
Enjoy the writing time, just
like it takes years for athletes
to become professional,
or a musician,
it's the same as developing
writing skills.
So just enjoy it.
Yeah, right here.
>> Why did you, put it
on the first book that,
Duff would be helping the Princes
in Black but, it never happened?
>> Oh, yes.
So Duff the goat boy, we suggest in
the first book that he might help
out the Princess in Black and
become his own super hero.
And it's taken awhile, hasn't it?
But I might say book 4
might answer your question,
it comes out in November.
Yeah, right here.
>> How did you get the idea
for Rapunzel's Revenge?
>> Rapunzel's Revenge
came, my husband,
I think this is actually our
last question, I'm so sorry,
but if you find me right
afterwards, I would be happy
to answer your question
and then I'm going
to be signing from
3 to 4 down there.
But so, Rapunzel's Revenge was a
graphic novel like a comic book
that my husband and I wrote.
He was a lifelong comics reader
and I didn't, was not interested
in comics until I married him.
And we thought, how could
bring our two loves together,
my first love is fairy tales,
and his first love
was super hero comics.
So we were like what fairy
tale character could we turn
into a comic book super hero?
And we decided, Rapunzel,
because she's got that long hair.
And she, when she's locked up in
her tower, she starts to practice
with those braids ad use
them as whip and lasso.
And so we set it in the
Old West and she escapes
from the tower and becomes a hero.
So that's how we came
up with that idea.
>> Are you going to make a
book 2, of Rapunzel's Revenge?
>> We did make a book 2,
today's your lucky day sir.
It came out in 2009, it's called
Calamity Jack and it's based
on her friend who is Jack
from Jack and the Beanstalk.
I can't believe how fast 30
minutes went, you guys are awesome.
Thanks so much for my helpers,
thanks for the great questions.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.